voici militant gay chef et
copropriétaire du tout nouveau resto le
bavard et l'ivrogne à sept îles on l'a
mis au défi de nous concocter une
assiette boréale à partir de produits
lepreau il a accepté et ça donne ceci
appétissant non mais avant d'y goûter
retour dans le temps à la recherche des
produits du terroir de la conclure voici
bruno duguay sa maison de la chine
goûter a pignon sur rue depuis déjà 15
sur la route loeb tout le monde nous dit
qu'il fallait absolument qu'on arrête
vous voir qu'est-ce qui est aussi
exceptionnel chez vous à la maison de la
chicoutai ben écoute heures parade
jusqu'au mondial y décèle pas le beurre
du shooter qu'est ce que vous mettez
nalbert déchets coûte et on ne peut pas
le dire notre succès c'est une recette
laussucq et ses bords et des
coffres-forts bon ben on va apporter ça
à notre ami chef pour qu'ils fassent
anar lâche écouter est un petit fruit
qui pousse dans les tourbières en région
nordique
c'est devenu le fruit emblématique de la
côte nord faut retenir qui en a un par
plein de l'eau la rareté pique nique ou
parce que c'est pas comme les fraises
sincèrement sports mécaniques mais
qu'est-ce que ça goûte à écouter cet
incident j'ai vu j'ai pas capable de le
décrire à part le côté acidulé niang ou
ben écoutez c'est ça que je dis aux gens
est-ce que la fraise doute la france bat
ça goûte le shooter
on fait un arrêt au grenier boréale une
coque qui osent cultiver des fruits et
légumes dans un environnement peu
favorable à l'agriculture
et ça marche tomates salades bâtissons
ne sont que quelques-uns des légumes
offerts ici
pouvez vous compter un jour avec les
magnifiques etienne la chance c'est le
grand manitou de ce qui est cultivé ici
ils nous offrent aussi ceux ci ça c'est
de la livèche a un goût de faire cesser
les risques l'ange entre les deux passes
consomme près ans a amené paix ou dans
un seau t il vraiment ça pousse une
manière naturelle
chirac contre j'aimerais qu'on aime la
côte nord
c'est aussi l'accès à la mer et une
belle gamme de poissons et de fruits de
mer à la poissonnerie du havre ont
choisi de belles petites crevettes
nordiques
oui elles sont transformées en guest
physique mais elles sont belles bien
pêcher ici au fumoir le gua niche on
repart avec une grille est au saumon et
un bon morceau de saumon pêché nouveau
brunswick
mais fumer ici ce pétoncles qui veut
nous faire la conversation a été
cultivée par la compagnie pur mère
spécialisée aussi dans la culture de
moule devant une des sept îles on
reprend la route avec pétoncles et al
[Musique]
dernier arrêt chez de bd de sève
l'entreprise danic la treille on la
trouve en pleine récolte la flore du thé
du labrador surtout l'accueillir en
bordure de mer est quelque chose de brut
dans la manga ni au niveau des arômes au
niveau de aussi du climat et de
l'environnement il quelque chose de 2
d'un peu dur d'un peu mais mais en même
temps d'incroyable et diversifiée annick
a quitté montréal il y à 11 ans pour
s'établir ici sur la côte nord la petite
ella mangani mais la fleur qu'on est
kevin tantôt est une des parties de ce
mélange qui est qui regroupe le thé du
labrador le sapin la maisonnée vrille et
les cdd - au moins deux vielles oui on
est en forêt puis ça c'est vosges les
que vous faites nous les aromates 6e
sont dégelés d'accompagnement donc je
vais de sapin baumier schl et de thé du
labrador
si vous vous avez une proposition nous
faire avec avec cette gelée la caisse
qui faites vous moi ce que j'aime
beaucoup ces crèches des crêpes de
sarrasin avec tartiner avec ou le sapin
ou le thé j'aime bien les deux et
ajouter une belle grosse noix de yogourt
nature mais la plus riche le dise pour
ça rien ça fait de très beau et long
déjeuner on a beaucoup de plantes de
bord de mer
la sabline l'épinard de mer le pertinent
avec lequel on travaille pour le pesto
si différent du pesto qu'on connaît
habituellement avec avec le basilic mais
je reçois plus rafraîchissant ça + +
frais ou vraiment bon merci pour tout et
elle découvert retour à sept-îles avec
notre panier de provisions bien remplie
inspiré le chef s'affaire à mettre de
l'avant les différentes saveurs et
textures de notre récolte
on est un peuple nordiques on travaille
trois quatre mois par année pour
développer nos produits par marie va y a
plus rien qui pousse fait qu on apprend
à développer des recettes par rapport à
ça
la sueur froide avec le bouillon on a
mis le livèche avec le persil mer on a
mis les champignons crabe de cette île
avec les algues de la main de la firme
permettre la gelée du thé du labrador
on a faim fusée ça le saumon fumé qu'on
a dû du fumoir d'aguanish avec le pesto
de personnes mer on a mis aussi la
rillettes de saumon fumé du mois
d'agonie ch avec son ami de chou qui
renaît boréale et on a aperçu en
chiffonnade sur le dessus un peu de
citron et le sucre et de la gym et amie
elle aussi recette sucrée de débauche on
prend un peu de perso ça me rajoute un
peu seul avec les rillettes belle
réussite et pour la seconde assiette le
ceviche de patong de la ferme sur mer
avec les cravates dur saint pierre en
dessous on a mis une statistique on fait
ici ses disques avec du concombre de
l'ail du miel la pistache le persil de
mer et la gelée de shipton c'est
tellement bon le côté sucré ou écouter
avec pétain puis les couloirs sont très
belles
oui ces deux assiettes ne sont qu'une
partie du terroir de la côte nord les
gens sont pas assez habitué à mener
porter leurs produits directement
restaurant faire valoir leur propre du
locaux qui sont dans courage des gens
qui en ont à nouveau repris à dire
développer avec nous le style de demain
[Musique]